c'est ce qu'on vaut la peine a donc des
conditions de temps disons de voyages
atroce les traversées mettra beaucoup de
gens inquiets moule et l'histoire de
l'esclavagé dans leur programme scolaire
ces élèves de cm2 de l'école francis
poulenc de guyancourt ce plomb ce matin
dans l'histoire française
quand j'ai pas de france je parle de la
france on apprenait aujourd'hui parce
que la france via las le département
d'oto mer donc ce n'est pas trop tôt
mais si on s'intéresse de l'histoire la
colonisation
le délestage donc la martinique la
guadeloupe la réunion et guyane
c'était un endroit où était un des lieux
découverte de termes propres à l'
esclavage des dates clés de cette
histoire mais aussi des ouvrages
accessibles à tous autour de cette
notion
ça ma fille du mal pour eux parce qu'ils
avaient rien fait et j'ai été des
esclaves nos manuels scolaires
maintenant
abordent lé esclavage de façon explicite
mais le programme d'histoire est très
large
et puis chaque année de plus en plus
large puisqu'on a toute l'histoire du
20e siècle puisqu'une somme 21e siècle
donc en fait on n'a pas toujours
l'occasion de pouvoir approfondir cette
cette histoire la semaine de la mémoire
de l'esclavagé sur saint quentin en
yvelines continue jusqu'au 10 mai date
de la journée nationale des mémoires de
la traite de l'esclavagé et de leurs
abolitions